- They are finally here,
the Apple Air Tags.
These have been rumored
for years at this point.
I feel like every time
there's an Apple event,
we think that they are gonna be announced,
and they haven't been,
but they're finally here.
We've got them in the studio to test out.
I'm so excited about this
because I lose a lot of stuff.
I'm not happy about it, but
it's just who I am as a person.
And that's just, I've accepted that.
(gentle melodic music)
They've got two different
variations right now
that you can purchase on the website.
You can get the one pack for
$29 or the four pack for 99.
And what's really cool about these
is they are fully customizable
with emojis or text.
So you are able to do that
when you purchase them.
We've also got some accessories.
We've got a loop, a leather
loop, and a leather key ring.
Let's open these up, set them
up, and let's chat about it.
Here's the box.
It is a tiny little package.
Oh wow.
Oh man, this is so exciting
because it's been a while
since there has been
sort of a new product category for Apple,
and this is an all new product.
(gentle music)
(machine beeps)
Hello?
So, this water and dust resistant.
It has an IP67 rating, which
means you can submerge it
in about one meter of
water for about 30 minutes.
I don't recommend doing that,
but just know that you should be okay.
It does have a replaceable battery.
This should last you up to a year.
And the battery is just one of those
CR2032 coin cell batteries.
So it should be pretty easy
just to replace the battery after a year.
This looks like those
little collector pins
that you would get at Disney.
I should honestly wear this around
just so I can find myself.
Look at that beautiful Apple logo.
Hey Tyler, you want to see this?
Isn't it cool?
- Oh it's very cute.
- It is very cute.
- [Tyler] Oh my God.
- We also have a four-pack.
We also have accessories to get into
Oh, look at the four pack.
Look, there's four! In the four pack!
Four, one, two, three, four.
(gentle music)
(plastic crinkling)
Look at them.
Okay, the customization
looks very, very cool.
I already have my
customization picked out.
I'm going to be doing a skull,
a pig, a poo, and an alien.
Let's open up our accessories now.
First up we have our Air loop tag.
Air loop tag? Air Tag loop?
It's all the same really.
Ooh, oh wow.
I am so into this yellow color recently,
ever since I saw the iMac
in that beautiful yellow color.
Like this looks so good.
There's a little snap right there.
Open that up.
Pop in your Air Tag, close it up.
There's going to be so many cool
third party accessories with this.
One of the things that
I'm really excited about
with these Air Tags is
the endless possibility
of third-party accessories.
This one is by Dbrand and you can check it
out in the description link below.
A huge thank you to
Dbrand for always being
so supportive of my channel.
They made this Air Tag key ring attachment
that's fully customizable
with the Dbrand skin
in the color of your choice.
It'll come with both a key ring
and a lanyard attachment
all for under $20.
I feel like one of the
most common use cases
is putting Air Tags on keys.
So this is a perfect, slim,
cost-effective accessory for it.
And then this just snaps like that.
It's cute.
So this has a pretty snug fit.
Ooh leather loop, fancy.
(gentle music)
So even though this is a leather,
like these both kind of feel very similar.
So I feel like if you are
not wanting a leather one
like that's totally fine
because this one feels almost the same.
Obviously the difference here is you have
this really nice stitching.
This is a little bit higher quality
but this still is pretty,
pretty substantial as well.
Alright, next up, we've
got the leather key ring.
I can't even tell you guys
how many times I lose my keys.
Like, I'll just be like
looking for my keys
mostly because I know that they have
a SIM card ejector on it
and I'm always needing one.
So not only will I be able to find my keys
but I'll always be able to
find a SIM card ejector.
Oh, this is very nice.
Look at that.
So it looks like this also has
a little snap, just like so.
I'm going to put a blank one on here.
Yeah, that looks nice.
So one of the things that
makes these different
than other tile trackers
is this has access
to the entire Find My network.
And what that means is anybody who has
Find My on their phone,
you're going to be basically piggy-backing
off of other people's phones and Bluetooth
to be able to find your lost items.
Now, something that's kind of cool is
if I lose I don't know, like my jacket
or my purse or whatever and
I mark that item as lost.
And then Tyler is, you
know, wherever I left it
he ends up seeing, oh my
goodness there's a purse
and he's rummaging around
or there's one of these tags on there.
It would send him a
notification that would say,
hey Justine lost this.
It would take you to a webpage with
either a phone number or a message
to anybody that finds it
on a way to contact me,
to get me my last item back.
That's cool.
Another thing that a lot of
people were saying on Twitter
is they had a really big
concern about privacy.
This is not going to be
giving away your location
or the location of anybody's phone
who actually was able to
help you find your lost item.
All of that is encrypted and
completely stays private.
There were also concerns
about slipping one of these
into somebody's bag or
attaching it to something
and being able to track their whereabouts.
A few things to kind of
keep your mind at ease.
The first thing is if Tyler
was to slip this into my backpack, Tyler.
Anytime this sensed some sort of motion,
it would make a sound.
It would also send a
notification to my phone
saying that there was a tag nearby
that did not belong to me.
Which is kind of cool
because you can just picture
that sort of pop up that would come up
whenever you open up
somebody else's Air Pods
next to your phone.
They're like, these are not your Air Pods.
I imagine it's very similar to that.
It's like, yo, there's a
tag nearby, it's not yours.
So they definitely are
keeping that in mind
because I feel like that
is a number one concern
on anything that has
tracking capabilities.
It's a combination of the Find My network
and Bluetooth that will
help you find your items.
And also if you have
one of the newer iPhones
with the U1 chip enabled you'll be able
to use precision tracking.
This is pretty cool because
you could take your phone
and kind of walk around
and it will direct you
right to your device.
Now, something else that
kind of crossed my mind
is how incredible this is going to be
for the accessibility community.
And one of my friends, James Rath
is making a video talking about
how he's going to be able to use these
as a legally blind person.
So I'm so excited to see his video.
He actually sent this little
message for us right here.
- Hi, my name is James Rath.
I'm a documentary
filmmaker, YouTube creator
and I was born legally blind.
I like to share the perspective
of being visually impaired
while interacting with technology
or accessible experiences like traveling.
One of my favorite
things about the Air Tags
like most Apple products
it's actually designed
with accessibility in mind.
That means that as a blind user,
I can use the Find My app
and have everything narrated to me.
Including the precision tracking.
So it can give me sort of this scheme
of hot or cold or Marco
Polo to find my items.
Which, as a blind person happens a lot.
I never thought I'd say this,
but thanks to the Air Tags.
I'm actually looking
forward to losing things.
- Thank you for the video,
James, you're the best.
Make sure you guys go
check out his channel
and subscribe and also check out his video
and say that IJ Army has sent you.
So now I think it's
officially time to set these
up and get tracking.
(light, upbeat music)
Well I'm gonna go hide,
while Tyler hides these
so that we can have a fun
little Air Tag scavenger hunt.
Here you go, Tyler, are you ready?
- [Tyler] You can just leave them there.
- I'll just leave them here.
Okay bye.
(slow, upbeat music)
- Is it time?
Let's do this.
The items, they're there.
Let's go find them.
So I have a list of my items here.
So the first one that
I'm going to try to find
is the one that's labeled EWT.
So I'm going to click on that.
It looks like it popped up on the map.
I'm going to play the sound.
- That's cheating.
- That's what I want to do.
Okay, so I feel like
when you play the sound
it's kind of giving you like
a sense of where it's at.
And then when you click into find nearby,
Oh, check this out.
This is cool.
Okay, so it's 13 feet away from me.
I'm getting closer.
It's to my left.
I don't know my left and right.
It's so close.
(slow beeping)
(rapid beeping)
Oh, look it says here!
I found it!
That's actually incredible.
Oh, it smells so good, smells like coffee.
We did that, EWT.
Mine. pocket.
Now we're gonna try to find this one.
This is in my backpack.
Let me see where this
looks like it might be.
Signal's weak.
It's weak.
(gasps) 30 feet, 24,
20, 18, we're so close.
Is it under here?
I didn't even see it, it matches!
Oh this definitely has
dog pee all over it now.
(rapid beeping) It's been found.
Oh this is fun.
Next up, we're going
to try to find my bike.
I hear it.
(rapid beeping)
It's everywhere.
There it is (laughs)
That's a sneaky good hiding spot Tyler.
Sneaking good.
Into the pocket.
I'm like making record time.
17, our connection is weak.
It's behind me, it's on my right.
It may be on a different level than you.
It's nearby, nearby.
Whoa! There it is.
All right, we have one more to find.
(rapid beeping)
(rustling through papers)
It's weird because the sound
is such a weird, like echoing sound that
(beeping)
Wait a minute, is this in my pocket?
Where is it?
Oh, God.
It's right there.
It's really accurate though.
Cause like it kept saying
that it was sort of right here
but then it's like, no, it's right here.
Here, here it is.
Well, I found them.
That was actually really fun.
We need to do a bigger
scavenger hunt, hmm...
I've got some ideas.
So that was a quick little scavenger hunt
and a nice demonstration
of how these would work
if you're looking for
something around your house.
One of the things that I
haven't got a chance to
yet try is the lost mode.
So when I do test that out,
I'll be sure to either post it here
or post it on Twitter or on Instagram.
So you guys can see a demo
of what that looks like.
But I'm very excited about these
mostly just because
they are small, compact
and they work perfectly
in the Apple ecosystem.
Tyler, are you surprised
how quick I found them?
Like I think I did a pretty good job.
- [Tyler] A little bit, yeah.
- Yeah. I mean you're
hiding spots were good.
- [Tyler] I could have done better.
- They were no match
though, for the Air Tags.
If you guys are new here,
I make a bunch of fun tech videos
and I would love for you guys to subscribe
if you're not subscribed already.
Hit the bell so you'll be
notified when I post new videos
and of course join our fun
community in the comments below.
And with that, I'll see
you guys in the next video.
I now need to go rename
these appropriately
and distribute them into all of my items.
I'm going to definitely
put one on my bike.
This matches my bike.
- [Tyler] Do you lose your bike a lot?
- Well
no. Do you?
- [Tyler] I don't have a bike.
- Yeah, you do.
- Oh yeah.
- You have a bike. (laughs)
(upbeat music)